does the Democratic party have a problem
with this issue it used to be the case
that you could be a Libertarian and a
liberal at the same time I feel like
that's gone away I would say we're still
we're the more pro-freedom and
pro-liberty of the two parties but it's
a low bar right I mean you have
Republicans trying to micromanage what
you do in your bedroom who you love when
you have kids I mean all these very
intimate things it's scary it really is
right but yeah you'll also have some on
the left that want to manage how you
live your lives but as somebody who is
pro-freedom I've never had any trouble
on the Democratic side I wish the
Democratic party was even more
pro-freedom but I do think we advance
the cause and this was a
a uh
a big night for LGBT
uh I think we have two lesbian Governors
now
[Applause]
are we over the gay hump I mean as far
as like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they encouraged me to do the wrong
things no no but you know what I'm
saying it's like it's a non-issue now I
mean and it wasn't a lot long ago when
it was an issue not you couldn't even
think about running yeah people it was
in issue and now you can be elected to
almost any office it doesn't seem like
it matters almost anywhere in the
country it was still a thing bill when I
ran for congress running for governor
some of the you know Democratic Elder
Statesmen they said oh you're going to
lose our state to Republicans our state
will never elect somebody who's gay you
know trying to pressure me out of it but
to their credit the people of Colorado
people in Massachusetts and Oregon said
it doesn't matter what we cares about
what you stand for what you're going to
do it doesn't matter who you are
America can change can it you know it's
very
uh do you think when you run for
president
um
it actually could be an advantage
because the Democratic party
um is very big on checking boxes
and it's very hard to imagine any ticket
now for on the Democratic side that
would have just two straight
white men
it's impossible to imagine
so they need to check boxes you check
one of them look you know I mean first
of all I have the job I love I'm really
passionate about Colorado hope everybody
visits Colorado enjoys college so you'll
never run 14.
um I love this job that I have this is
the job I wanted
um look it's not it's not a bad thing
that the Democratic party wants to look
like America I mean I think it is good
that you have a party you know on Race
on gender on all these different on
faith on all these different factors I
mean you want to look like America
people should be able to look at
themselves in the mirror and say hey
there's somebody like me in Congress or
somebody like me on the Supreme Court
that's a good thing it is a good thing
but the the question though is is it the
priority I think that's what people
hesitate sometimes about the Democrats
is it more of a priority than things
like Merit that should matter more is it
more of a priority than facts or science
yeah it never should set in the way of
Merit right you always want the best
president the best member of Congress
um but what I think it's exciting at
least where the Democrats are uh and I
think most Americans are is these things
don't matter I mean we're look at look
at President Barack Obama right first
African-American president of the United
States of America an amazing president
of my opinion right I really great um
I've worked with them on a lot of
Education stuff did a great job so I
mean it's just these barriers that are
in people's minds still like somehow I
can't do this I think these are falling
away and there really is no barrier for
anybody of any background no matter
their race who they are who they love
their faith or or if they're of no faith
at all there's really no no impediment
there to serve in any office well I
don't know about the no faith at all
yeah I think there's a I I don't think
an atheist could get elected dog catcher
in this case you know one of my one of
my uh friends in Congress Jared Huffman
Northern California he's an uh a
humanist and now he's a you know an
atheist humanist uh and he won by record
margins in Northern California and he's
uh I think the first in the United
States Congress to to openly identify as
a non-believer well there's one yeah